i think you can sell a lot a lot of
books by creating
some access to you what would you do if
you're launching a book
going into this year next year giving
away an ungodly amount of books is a
good idea
today's episode of model masters is
brought to you by tubebuddy
tubebuddy is your best friend on your
road to youtube success
i use it every day on my channel to get
more views and subscribers
automate the boring tasks and split test
my thumbnails and titles
i've done over 3 800 split tests which
have led to results like taking this 5
year old video
that was getting 250 views a day and
just by changing the thumbnail it blew
up to 15
000 views per day you can get started on
tubebuddy for
free at tubebuddy.com evan
evan it's good to see you thank you for
having the empathy there congrats on all
your success thanks for having me man
appreciate the love
my question for you was book marketing
like where would you take it now i've
got a i got a new book out around
service
and uh what would you do if you're
launching a book going into this year
next year
i remember when i launched crush it i
created this model
that was just kind of natural to me
because i was a retailer
of this kind of like buy five books have
this buy 25 books that they and
ferris at that point in 09 on the back
of four hour work week was just
at the tippy top and he sent me such a
nice you know dm of like
hey that was really smart you want to
talk can you talk me through that and
like
and now it feels like it's commonplace
of like but kevin i really think
tiered bulk buying is uncomfortably a
big deal
because what you learn about books
similar to empathy wines on your desk
but much easier with books than wine
because alcohol laws
those books find themselves into hands
you know when somebody buys 100 books
to get an hour with you those that
person
tends to be somebody you want to have
100 copies of your book
because they're going to be clever or
smart or thoughtful
or nice like they don't tend to that
person that knew that access to you
was good tends to not be the person that
lets those hundred books sit in a
warehouse or burns them
they use it as collateral so bulk for
sure
i also think so there's a dirty secret
that i believe and when i buy a sneaker
or not a sneaker when i buy a when i buy
or start a
candy or a deodorant like when i get to
my consumer good
business at in the next decade or two
you'll
notice that i'm sampling the living out
of it remember i said it
you're gonna see it so i think the same
thing with books i think one of the
number one things that book marketing
and marketers don't do well is realizing
giving away an ungodly amount of books
is a good idea
so another thing for you to consider
evan is it's not good to send me a book
and that's what everybody does
because i'm not are you kidding me like
it's no
but it's that next two tiers down
there's two thousand people in your
community that most people think
are the people you want to buy the book
that i actually think are exactly the
people that you should send the book
and then how you package that for them
to build awareness
or do other things a that person call
them
you know a cliche person
cliche meaning the comment i don't i
don't like that word the
person that we all know that if you have
a platform and you have a book
that is a solid fan of you and four
other people
has 13 000 followers on instagram
either a aspires to be like you
or expo inspired to extract value from
people like you
to do whatever they're up to that person
i think is super interesting
because that person getting a book from
you especially if you give it some
effort
really matters is not taken for granted
and oftentimes become very gracious
individuals during the book selling
process so
sampling taking out of your own budget
with your publisher 2000 like
my toughest i mean i get paid a lot at
this point because of how well i do with
books
my toughest part is not the seven figure
advance my toughest part for the book
publisher is they're emotional about how
many samples you should get
like they will pay me millions of
dollars like i can get an extra million
from them
for my book easier than i can get them
to give me 5 000 more copies to hand out
because they're emotional about the way
they think it should be done
so getting more copies to give away more
copies is one
and i think access tiered tiered
selling by five books this happens by 50
i mean look what we're doing right now
you know i did it in a different form
for for good but like
this was access that's very difficult to
get with me
and and and i think with i think you
could sell a lot a lot of books
by creating some access to you
for the reach out would you make it
based around the theme of the book
because it's not just a typical
how to make money book no okay no i
think actually awareness is awareness is
awareness believe it or not
i had a weird thing happen that i want
everybody here seven years ago we ran an
ad for some brand i don't remember where
we targeted britney spears fans
on facebook when you could do that and
it had nothing to do with britney spears
and it was by far the number one
converter
and i see sid your head's shaking you've
said open up here
you've seen some of those elements with
my content through the years right
i think the the example that you're
referring to is like the the cheese rank
one
where it was like it was hit me baby one
more time
very good sid go ahead tell him
it was the reason why i remember it
because andy ran that one so uh it was
really
cheese rang was like is a pop we had a
publishing
uh arm we were just creating a lot of
content around cheese and
yeah so we were trying to like by the
way it was just like by the way on the
record we do a lot of stuff that you
don't hear about
and it was just uh we're trying to just
try a lot of different
copies and headlines and everything and
like one of the
like and he was trying a lot of
different versions of it then one of
them
it was like he just thought about trying
britney spears fans and like
adding the headline which had hit me
baby one more time i think the
click-through rate went up by
almost 10x and that was like nothing to
do with britney spears it was a cheese
add
but just that's the things you kind of
learn a little bit
from like the billion dollar world i
play in with brands
like awareness is awareness awareness
that's where some of the logic around
the things we make fun of as
practitioners around
commercials or like a logo like
branding there's some real good digital
versions of that so they answer your
question
in a long-winded but i want to give more
value here the answer is no i wouldn't
i would go on awareness arbitrage
all right the reality is if drake holds
up your book and says this is cool
that's going to work
a small percentage of a big base is
going to
you know what i mean i'd love to get
drake let's make that happen
by the way evan getting drake and this
is again i'm trying to bring a lot of
value to everybody
so many of you have no idea who you can
get to
or to sample or try your products you've
said no without
asking i think evan from afar i've
watched
has done a good job early in his career
like a basking
and i think he's good at it and i'm and
i'm i i don't think
that's not one of the pillars that has
helped him get to where he's gotten to
as i've watched him for the last seven
or eight years
asking matters what's gonna happen
the thing that you know that's gonna
happen nobody's gonna reply from drake's
camp cool
next took you eight seconds to control c
and control v
yeah we're used to it evan thank you so
much for having a couple seconds
and being able to tell the believe
nation a little bit about empathy wines
it means a lot to me that you would take
this valuable
real estate and and time on your channel
to give me some love
means a lot it's just good karma points
and so you're just
you're awesome thank you believe nation
uh if you're into wine at all go to
empathywines.com
my whole career's work was poured into
producing a wine that
rivaled 40 to 60 wine for 20 bucks a
bottle
uh i'm just super excited about this
subscription-based wine business
you can order three six or twelve
bottles in subscription form rose white
red
um if you if you search on instagram or
twitter you will be blown away
people are literally like i don't even
like garyvee but the wine's good
super proud of the effort thanks evan
for the time uh wishing you guys all
happy and healthy if you want to change
your life for the next 30 days for free
check the link right here below me or if
you want to see the last time i did a
one-on-one with the garyvee check out
the video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there